patrick bon soir ça peut te dire que les
l'insultent qui t'a fait le plus mal
c'est une insulte que j'entends souvent
malheureusement c'est quand on écrit
patrick ça je supporte pas parce que
j'ai peur qu'on me confond avec
quelqu'un d'autre avec patrick sabatier
patrick sébastien et je tiens à lire ce
soir mon prénom c'est quand même au
risque quoi maurice qu'est ce que tu as
de plus sexy en toi pour certaines c'est
ma voix cassé ma voix cassée
maurice qu'est ce que tu écris quand on
me demande des autographes
j'ai envie d'écrire des tas de choses
j'ai envie d'écrire je t'aime c'est
super c'est génial c'est finalement je
dis rien à dire parce que le fait qu'on
me demande d'autographe sésame ça suffit
quoi y'a rien à ajouter c'est déjà super
est-ce que tu thème
souvent je me pose cette question quand
même atteint dans la glace et je me dise
que je suis un écossais avec moi même
mais
finalement il ya des jours où les
journaux mais depuis quelque temps il
faut que j'ai vraiment trouvé un
personnage sur un mois que qui s'est
révélé que j'aime beaucoup maurice tu
crois qu'il faut coucher pour réussir
je pense pas mais
je pense qu'il faut réussir pour coucher
c'est vrai dis moi c'est pas dur de
devenu une star au moment du sida
chocques toute façon le star system
c'est un formidable préservatif ça vous
préserver quelque chose entre république
et vous qui se passe qui est
complètement platonique et ça c'est
grand c'est beau et je pense quoi encore
par risque quand as-tu pleurer pour la
dernière fois
j'ai pleuré à montpellier je crois ou à
bordeaux je suis plus fins
sont mais personne n'a à toulouse enfin
c'était comment j'avais envie de pleurer
j'ai pleuré dans ma loge
je serai aussi de 20 à biarritz comme je
tiens à le dire et après demain je veux
être avant du son je crois que le plus
réussi
tu préfères draguer ou de faire draguer
j'ai pas le choix de toute façon le
droit tous les soirs
c'était 15000 à bordeaux je 12000 à
montpellier victime brax fou csu c'est
quelque chose qui nous dépasse quoi ce n
est pas empêché à montluçon ils sont
combien choix qui seront passés de 12000
à des réservations sont complètes tout
d'abord parce qu'elle est lassante
rédigeant la fin c'est la fête quoi
c'est génial c'est ce à quoi
reconnaît-on infailliblement la passion
naissante la patience et la flamme c'est
la flamme d'un briquet qu'on allait vous
connaissez et puis être flammes puis le
briquet plus être patient et plus la
couche d'ozone aussi maintenant et la
passion qui s'éteint
c'est quand il pleut gaz
merci morice et pour être sûr de ne rien
rater de dinars 10 tubes abonnez vous je
m'étais un peu ce bleu